again we just took come here take your
hands out of your pockets come here
what's up drop drop that stuff right now
turn around put your hands behind your
back that's turn around put your hands
behind your back goodness gracious stuff
I sat listen to what I say turn around
turn around it's just stuff I sat right
there why put your
hand hand tight
for I do stop I'm not doing nothing
wrong sir Dam what do you mean I ain't
done nothing wrong at all I was up here
with my people you were trying to rip a
TV off a wall they have cameras shut up
they have cameras I wasn't ripping shut
up I wasn't ripping the TV off the wall
sir look a crack pipe sir I wasn't
rubbing the t a wall let's go no I had
go to jail let's go go to jail for what
a crack pipe what crack pipe it's not a
crack pipe yeah it is hell no it's not
what is it then so that's not a crack
pipe go look at go look it that's not a
crack right being so mean sir stop see
this
is sir I didn't do nothing wrong okay
sir I didn't do nothing wrong at all all
right sir I've done nothing wrong at all
man please stop all right we talk about
what's going going on but I haven't done
nothing wrong sir at all you're trying
to rip the TV off the wall I wasn't
trying to rip the TV off the wall he has
cameras S I wasn't trying to light the T
Off the Wall yeah okay is it damaged no
sir going to be charging damaging if it
is okay it's not it's a seat okay yes
sir I haven't done nothing wrong though
yet you did though I haven't even done
nothing wrong sir you did I haven't sir
okay so I haven't done nothing all right
I haven't done nothing there someone
call right now get me out of
here someone get me out of jail right
now someone can get me out of jail right
now
fuck someone come get me out the jail
right
now someone come get me out of
here someone come get me
out this bullshit I didn't do nothing
wrong I wasn't doing nothing
wrong so call up here right
now right fucking
now this is
bullshit I skip this
shit get this shit out of here
Illuminati Illuminati get this shit out
of
here fuck this shit Illuminati get this
shit out of
here get this shit out of
here get this shit out of here okay we
want to thank Morgan and Morgan for
sponsoring this body cam video I mean I
think it's pretty clear from the body
cams that we cover that it's not always
safe out there when you're hurt it can
be confusing it can be scary you don't
really know where to turn well Morgan
and Morgan is actually the largest
injury law firm in America and in a time
when you already have so much to think
about they're going to make it super
easy for you they have completely
modernized the process because you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents you talk to your whole
legal Team all on your phone that's it
an attorney is going to review your case
in just eight clicks also they have
4,000 support staff that can help you
too which is just amazing to think about
and in terms of price well you only pay
them if you win there's no upfront fee
so if you're injured and you want to
join the over three million people that
call them every year you can submit a
claim at www. forthepeople.com
ELC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your
phone get it out
here get this shit out of
here get this cop away from
me right now
get this car from this store
away I was froming TV I was trying to
turn it on I was trying to turn it I get
these people
away get these people away from
me get that cop and get him
away get that cop and get him away from
me get him
away
get him away from me
please get him away from
me the
cop get him away from me
y get this cop away from
me get this cop
away I would I didn't do nothing wrong
sir
[Applause]
I'm
okay
hey where you
at thank you very much for grabbing him
we have tried to get him for months um
did he break that TV or was it already
broken broke a week ago so there is a
report fil okay um is where he broke it
and the officer has pictures of it he
also broke the other
TV um back in DEC that's BR there okay
I'll make sure to check out those
reports and then uh we'll see if we can
get a detect him to call you about
that um he's he had a he had drug play
famili on him so he's going to go to
jail today for that so we'll see about
the other charges once the detective uh
whatever detective is assigned to it
okay all right want the report number uh
[Music]
yeah all right
is
728 all right I'll take look at
that and and do you have the video do
you have the video saved of him breaking
it I havenn
[Music]
ITN it when we get home out of the all
right sounds good thank you
sir
all right I haven't done nothing okay so
what so so so what you trying to say
going to jail for what for having a me
fight for having a meth pipe you said
that's not a meth pipe is it it's a
dude's tire rod oh is it yeah this
that's my dude's tire rod yes okay yes
sir all
right that's my I do
stuff damn that's not even my stuff
anyway you were trying to pick it up
when I walked in no my it was all
sitting on the blue counter yeah it's
yours no it was on a blue counter okay
man please sir come on Sir
me so I got time for this stuff at 10:
in the morning man I was doing a bunch
of productive stuff yeah yeah man I
was I got too much stuff going on man
please I just got out of jail yesterday
please can I Ser I wasn't doing nothing
wrong at
all sir I wasn't doing nothing wrong at
all sir
please please I haven't done nothing
wrong at all sir I promise you I haven't
okay please I haven't done
nothing let run here start accusing me
sir I haven't done nothing
wrong I promise you I
haven't I you said you guys came up to
me ask me if I was a Walgreens I wasn't
at
Walgreens I wasn't that Walgreens it's
11: in the morning this is sad all I can
do is get Tracked Down by people all day
long
please all day
long fuck this
stuff
huh what is it
broke the TV I didn't break the TV I was
trying to turn the TV on sir I just got
there I was trying to turn the TV on sir
I didn't break
it I didn't break the TV sir at all yeah
somebody's came over the thing I said
yeah I'm not doing nothing wrong sir
that's what I said somebody came over
the thing I said I'm not doing nothing
wrong you guys came in I don't I didn't
have nothing on me
sir
guys are crazy man the
fuck you guys get HT get me out of
here this is bullshit sweeti I go
through this shit all every all the
goddamn every goddamn
day get this damn cop away from
me get this cop away from
me
get this cop away from
me get this cop away from me please
y'all please Illuminati I hate this
stupid shit I don't do nothing
wrong I don't do nothing wrong at
all I don't do nothing
wrong feel me
sweetie I don't do nothing wrong
Illuminati guys I don't do nothing
wrong I don't have a meth pipe it's my
dude it's my dude's shit it's my dude's
tire
rod that's my dude's tire rod
Rod tell my dude's tire
rod the
fuck it's my dude's tire
rod let me
go y let me go I haven't done
shit K me I haven't done shit
sweetie sweetie I haven't done nothing
at
all fuck this
shit give me fuck
shit to
what what what I saying so trying to say
taking me to jail go take it uh talk to
a detective all right so go talk to a
detective yeah sir okay where at uh the
police district on Wayne Avenue Police
District on Wayne Avenue
okay seat Bel yeah I got my seat
Bel
to detective talk to a detective on
Wayne
Avenue okay